chers collègues des batteries produites
en Europe réutilisez et recycler en
Europe voilà notre objectif je salue
l'adoption de ce règlement européen sur
les batteries qui établit d'énormes
claires pour l'éco-conception la
performance environnementale le
recyclage et la réutilisation des
batteries avec cette loi européenne
l'Europe démontre son engagement à
construire une industrie des batteries
fortes et écologiques nous faisons
également un pas en avant vers notre
objectif d'autonomie stratégique en
effet en favorisant le recyclage et la
réutilisation des matériaux critiques
nous réduisons notre dépendance aux
importations de ces matières premières
cela mène non seulement à une
utilisation plus efficace de nos
ressources mais contribuent également à
la création d'emplois et renforce la
compétitivité de l'industrie européenne
maintenant il est temps de mettre en
œuvre ces nouvelles règles et de FA
voriser l'implantation d'usine de
fabrication et de recyclage de batterie
partout en Europe nous avons déjà
commencé comme en France dans les hauts
de France avec une véritable vallée
européenne de la batterie faisant en
sorte que cela s'accélère encore merci